says her leg was sprayed with bullets 15
years ago
it was during a conflict between the
rwandan-backed armed group and
government forces here in Democratic
Republic of Congo
she struggled to walk ever since then
last month the M23 armed group attacked
her Village
the only thing I can remember is many
soldiers running away and shooting so
everybody started running I was in my
house and there was nothing I could do
but luckily a young man came and carried
me away on his back everything including
my wheelchair was left behind
Salome is one of dozens of people with
disabilities in this Camp who wanted to
speak to us
some of them lost Mobility at Birth or
later in life from untreated illness
most of those we met said they were
injured in past conflicts and they told
us they're struggling
they're among more than 800 000 people
who've been forced from their homes in
the last year as M23 widely understood
to be backed by neighboring Rwanda has
taken swathes of territory from
government forces in the East Rwanda
denies backing the group The Ground here
is made up of these sharp broken
volcanic rocks it's not a great place to
make a camp but there's nowhere else to
go most people are sleeping without even
mattresses on the floor and it makes it
extremely difficult for people in
wheelchairs or on crutches to get around
there are a few wheelchairs here since
most were abandoned when people fled
one like this made of bicycle parts
welded together cost about 75 dollars
[Music]
but people don't even have enough food
it takes hours of queuing just to get a
ration card
and then another day spent queuing as a
food distribution for some lentils and
rice
which this man can't carry back to his
tent without help
s trying to find all the people with
disabilities in this camp and register
what help they need
he's had shrapnel in his leg for 15
years
Charities estimate about one in seven
people in Congo have some kind of
disability
that means there are nearly a million
people with disabilities who've been
displaced
people with physical disabilities need
to be protected just like any other
person because they're human Medical
Services here are inadequate they might
be able to treat somebody with malaria
but they can't do anything in this Camp
to help people like me who need
specialist treatment or surgery
Decades of conflict and lacking Health
Services have already made life hard and
now yet more conflict has made it even
harder Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera bulengo
Democratic Republic of Congo